are now on night three of the battle for
the house speaker and we begin tonight
with some good news I can confirm major
negotiations have been going on all day
behind the scenes while these votes were
taking place today with Kevin McCarthy
and many of the Republican holdouts and
I can report that at this hour a
document is being put together that will
go a long way to settling differences
will it get Kevin to 218 we won't know
until probably sometime tomorrow maybe
Monday if anything would just probably
be a couple of votes short but certainly
progress it is real tonight at this hour
no doubt you the American people are
being patient but that patience is
wearing thin the vote totals remain as
of now unchanged three straight days we
have 200 Republicans supporting McCarthy
20 supporting somebody else in the past
24 hours Kevin McCarthy has made several
additional assurances to the holdouts
this is before these meetings today and
including a new one volt threshold for a
motion to vacate in other words one
Republican can force a vote to oust the
speaker if he doesn't keep his promises
and McCarthy also agreed to add Freedom
caucus members to the all-important
rules committee and committed to
stand-alone votes for each of the 12
approach Appropriations bills as well as
a vote on term limits for members of
Congress and again look at your screen
McCarthy has already laid out his
commitments to America it's on paper he
signed his name that is a promise in
cement he's given detailed promises on
the economy including less government
spending fewer regulations domestic
energy production energy Independence
protecting against China surrounding our
supply chain issues also promises
related to foreign policy border
security ending Biden's Catch and
Release and of course bringing back this
successful Trump policies On the Border
funding the police yes that's important
parental rights big Tech and big
government censorship election Integrity
protections for the first and second
amendments and a lot more to that
document he signed his name to it this
is an agenda that Republicans support it
includes key investigations oversights
affirm stance again all of Biden's
Reckless policies and by the way he has
agreed to every investigation we have
discussed up to date now Kevin McCarthy
does become speaker and he fails to live
up to the promises just one person can
initiate his removal and the agenda
seems to be pretty much in cement and it
is the America First agenda now keep in
mind these aren't the only promises
McCarthy made to Republican lawmakers
take a look at this
he led the conference to adopt
substantive reforms that will make our
majority more effective
let me list some of them Andrew Clyde's
proposal to restore public access to the
Capitol Lauren bober's proposal to
reduce the linkage between the nrcc and
the steering committee process Gary
Palmer's proposal to cap spending on
suspension bills Scott Perry's proposal
for additional conference meetings ahead
of key votes Bob Good's proposal on
stand-alone Appropriations bills Andy
Biggs proposal limiting suspension
waivers from committees chip Roy's
proposal to make co-sponsors Amendment
co-sponsored amendments in order a firm
72-hour publication of bills before
calling for a recorded vote an end to
proxy voting and into remote
participation in committee work by
members of Congress
now let me be clear Kevin McCarthy is
still the odds on favorite to become
speaker now some members have stated
that they will not vote for McCarthy no
matter what these quote never Kevin's
whatever you want to call them they
don't have a plan to install another
speaker as a matter of fact almost every
day they nominate somebody else there's
no with the motion to vacate however and
all these other concessions and complete
agreement on the agenda as it relates to
investigations his commitments to
America it's kind of time that they
start getting to work now this all
should have been done before January 3rd
as of now there is no viable alternative
or a concrete vision for the country
moving forward I know the Democrats are
loving it I know the media mob is loving
it I hope members will remember they are
supposed to be public servants they are
to serve you the public that put them in
office that gave them the opportunity to
lead at some point in the near future
House Republicans will need to put aside
their differences is and actually govern
follow the commitments for America
follow the investigations and do the
will of the American people the GOP now
holds a slim majority in one half of one
branch of government they will not have
the power to totally reimagine how our
federal government conducts business
however they will have the power of the
purse the power of subpoena they can
bring in Biden officials they can expose
corruption if it exists in the doj and
the FBI they can hold Anthony fauci
accountable they can hold Adam Schiff
accountable Eric's Falwell accountable
big Tech accountable and the Biden
family Syndicate accountable and say no
to Biden's Reckless agenda that is what
McCarthy has promised to do in writing
with the help of people like Jim Jordan
Jim Comer Steve scalise and others that
is what 200 House Republicans have
already signed off on again if they
don't do their job fire them here's a
question what would Reagan do now he
famously told his staff I hope these
people in D.C might listen the person
who agrees with you 80 percent of the
time is a friend and an ally not a 20
Trader Republicans might be wise to heed
that advice anyone else is now holding
out in the name of some vague Vision to
drain the swamp without an actionable
plan is not looking out for you the
American people instead they're looking
for attention for themselves the
American people certainly deserve good
governance and better hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else